what if i told you there is a game out
there that is unlike anything you have
ever seen or if i told you you could use
cryptocurrency to buy and breed
creatures which are literal nfts
i'm being serious it is like pokemon but
with real world consequences and for
some people it is taking over their
lives
[Music]
all right y'all before i get into the
video i gotta remind you as always hit
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring that notification bell if you
don't you me staying on the shelf
forever and pymon's leaving so
it's really up to you so there's this
game called axi infinity if you haven't
heard of it basically it's a free to
start playing pokemon inspired game like
that is absolutely jigglypuff's uncle
who shows up every two thanksgivings and
has stories no one wants to hear and yes
folks we are going to be talking about
crypto
yay
i did not think this would ever be
happening when i took this job so uh
shout out to liz who worked really hard
to graduate [ __ ] laude
with a degree in political science now
you probably haven't heard of axio
infinity because in the grand scheme of
things it's a relatively small and
pretty odd game
but you might want to know that the game
has over a million players that joined
in the past year also a rare plot of
digital land in the game sold for 2.3
million dollars and the game itself has
been valued at 3 billion while getting a
125 million dollar investment do i have
your attention now in order to
understand how a bunch of pixels can be
sold for the same price as a pretty nice
house in the suburbs we had to start all
the way back at the beginning axi
infinity developed by sky mavis is a
game that described itself as a pokemon
inspired universe where anyone can earn
tokens through skilled gameplay and
contributions to the ecosystem players
can battle collect rays and build a
land-based kingdom for their pets and
when we say tokens we mean crypto tokens
yes we are going to be learning today
folks axi infinity is also technically
an esport holding tournaments and
qualifiers that have crypto prizes
casters vods like any other esport and
not to be outdone
they have a song axa gaming axia gang
axia gang axia gang axia gang axia gang
axia gang x again
this is a game that uses cryptocurrency
and real-life money and wraps it up in
one pokemon like bow before we go any
further let's back up and do a little
bit of a cliff notes review of crypto
for everyone admittedly i hated ap econ
in high school but here is a very
oversimplified explanation of
cryptocurrency simply put cryptocurrency
is virtual money in the form of digital
tokens ownership information is stored
in a public ledger with strong
protection to secure online transactions
bitcoin dogecoin all crypto crypto may
seem like an easy thing to write off or
even just make fun of but it is a real
financial ballpark being used to make
real money remember when dogecoin
exploded in value earlier this year or
take a look at your bank app probably
gonna ask you about crypto and if you're
interested whether you like it or not
crypto is here and at the very very
least it is important to know about the
first thing you should know about this
game is that it has been dubbed a play
to earn game before you can start
playing the game you need to buy
monsters or as they're called in this
universe
axes axes are nfts you need a minimum of
three to play the game and the lowest
costing axes run about 300
so you're looking at an almost 1 000
payment just to start playing the game
and you pay for this using ether
ethereum which is a cryptocurrency like
bitcoin this is a very different kind of
pay-to-play but
here we are and as nfts go that axi is
exclusive to you just as all nfts are in
theory and again a very oversimplified
explanation for nfts nfts or
non-fungible tokens are items that have
unique data and that cannot be traded
some famous nfts you might have heard
about are like the disaster girl meme
where like the house is burning right
here and she's like
and then another one where edward
snowden's court documents were made into
a portrait of edward snowden so you
purchase your team of axes which are
nfts using ether ethereum which is
cryptocurrency great
now what now you can do a lot and i
believe tech creator casey newton put it
best for the verge axes are unique
digital objects stored on axi's own
blockchain to create new ones existing
owners must breed them by spending
currency earned within the game or
purchased from an exchange by winning
battles in the game or selling axes to
the other players owners can earn the
game's currencies those earnings can be
then sold on the open market for real
money generating income for players if
you need to replay that one more time i
absolutely do not blame you but these
earnings are no joke they're giving some
players a livelihood via a game that is
a pokemon knockoff that uses
cryptocurrency rest of world reported
that a 31 year old man's hour of play a
day earns him twice the money of his
last job which was selling rice feed to
farmers he's able to provide for himself
and his 81 year old grandmother earning
10 000 philippine pesos a month another
filipino player said on facebook that he
bought two houses with the money he
earned from playing axey infinity and
he's not the only player in the
philippines that has talked about the
money they have made via the game it
should be noted reports differ on how
many players of axe infinity are from
the philippines but it's anywhere
between 40 to 55 of the player base in
fact it's become such a big deal the
philippine government has taken notice
of the game as a taxable source of
income but remember to even play the
game you have to drop about 1 000
so this has created an opportunity for
opportunists to do their thing the
financial times reported that two people
launched a company that will cover the
beginning costs quote taking up to half
their earnings in exchange for access to
the game this company is not alone in
their ventures with other similar
ventures doing the same some people want
to play the game so badly that they post
information about their candidacy online
in hopes of being sponsored but while
some players earn lots of money from
playing that is not the case for
everyone the financial times also
reported that according to an outside
analysis quote in the past three months
all but the most experienced players
have earned below daily average wage in
the philippines some low-skilled players
drop below minimum wage beginning in
september after factoring in the cut
taken by sponsors to be clear if this
analysis is true after the cut is given
to the lenders many of these players are
not making piles of money because of
this game the lenders themselves are
sponsoring people because they want to
make more money than they would be
playing the game by themselves and
that's not me saying that that's
literally part of the opening of the
financial times article i've been
talking about it's also a good time to
mention that the way sky mavis makes the
money is by taking a cut of the
transactions made in the game about 4.5
percent and apparently they've made 2
billion that's billion with a b
dollars in revenue but there are more
issues it wouldn't be a story about
crypto without issues come on y'all look
at this graph for a token in-game smooth
love potion and look at that
depreciation or in other words
how it tanked according to the financial
times the reason this is happening is
because players are now exchanging these
tokens for money like real money rather
than putting them back into the game
financial times also said that this has
greatly impacted people in developing
nations who play the game
self-admittedly axe infinity says that
quote axi is a 100 player owned real
money economy rather than selling game
items or copies the developers of the
game focus on growing the player to
player economy you can think of axi as a
nation with a real economy axi
population growth is a major factor
within the axi ecosystem axs slp tokens
face similar economic forces that need
to be managed so in short it relies on
people which if that sounds absolutely
terrifying to rely on your fellow peers
gamers for your source of income
it is people can be really scary at the
end of the day why does this all matter
why should we even care about a pokemon
knockoff game that uses cryptocurrency
well whether you like it or not this is
a legitimate game with legitimate money
behind it there are lots of people
playing this game and people are trying
to and sometimes succeeding and making
money from it someone used to work at
goldman sachs said that his income from
playing the game would be more than his
salary at the bank
and when he left goldman sachs in 2020
he did it because he said crypto would
have widespread adoption axs a
governance token for the axe universe
has soared 25 000
since the beginning of the year that is
an insane amount of growth if anything
axi infinity and games like it because
yes other games do exist
will continue to exist and are likely to
grow it's just a matter if you're
willing to pay attention personally it's
a little weird to me that a game like
this exists and like half-life 3 doesn't
i am very happy that people can have an
additional or sole source of income that
is physically safer for them in the
pandemic that could really really
benefit them but it makes me upset that
it is not guaranteed and i i know that's
just economics and also none of this is
financial advice i just spent 250 on
genjen impact crystals so do not take
any financial advice from me
people were so mad about you me
they were like
they were so mad
they're like
i can't believe you're a yumi
sympathizer and i went what are you
going to do about it babe what are you
going to do about it
run i have the zoomies i can catch up to
you
what are you going to do
oh
i just dethroned paimon
oh my i'm so sorry pineland
well whether you like it or not this is
a legitimate game with legitimate money
behind it
excuse me excuse me but this is the
amber cult and i want everyone to know